So we've just finished learning about interpreters and formal semantics.
We touched briefly on the halting problem.
Surprisingly, although the halting problem officially is impossible to solve,
it's actually one of my favorite areas in computer science.
The halting problem and its cousin, Rice's Theorem,
are sometimes informally known as the
Law of Interpreter/Writer Employability.
Because it's officially impossible to solve all these problems and get them right every time,
there's always a market for people who can make
closer approximations or be almost right,
be right most of the time, be right with high probability.
We know it's impossible to do absolutely correctly,
but nothing stops us from being 99.999% correct.
So we keep trying, with closer and closer approximations.
In fact, a few years ago, with a student, I was trying to do just that.
We wanted to look at a programmed source code
and guess which lines were likely to be executed frequently
without actually running the program.
If we could solve this formally,
we could definitely solve the halting problem.
So we know it's impossible,
but we can solve it before a subset of programs or be often right.
You might imagine looking at the recursive definition for Fibonacci.
If you're calling Fibonacci of ten,
the recursive call happens much, much more frequently
than the base case that just returns one.
Is there some way we can look at how humans write programs
and figure out what's common based on that?
It turns out we were able to extract
this sort of structural information or comments
that are present in human written programs
and figure out for them which lines are more or less likely to be executed,
or executed more or less frequently at run time.
So even though the problem is impossible to solve in practice,
we actually view this as an opportunity.
Because it's not possible to get it exactly right,
we want to come as close as we can and reach for the stars.